all right good evening everybody my name
is shannon rose mcauliffe i'm joined
here by theo fields
say hello theo we are here to present
the
fifth workshop in the creative arts
competition series this evening
we have miguel rodriguez with us and
he's going to be taking us through
these sort of fundamental pillars of a
non-profit
business plan so um we'll do a bit of
presentation
and then we will open the thing for q a
we'll have some really lively discussion
and
you know with that uh i will just turn
it over to miguel to give a quick self
introduction and then
get us underway so great thank you so
much uh shannon rose
and thank you thea for inviting me to be
part of this
series of workshops that you are
offering um i
am the founder and president of athlone
artist which is an artist representation
agency uh it's a boutique agency
representing about 51
artists so far internationally these are
classical musicians
opera singers conductors and stage
directors
i spent the past 25 years
working in the arts management sector
um managing some of massachusetts uh
most interesting organizations such as
boston baroque where i spent my last
eight years before i founded my agency
and
opera boston the boston landmarks
orchestra the full aircraft museum
and um and a few more um
so what i figure i'm gonna share my
screen because i'm gonna do
a little bit of a power point
presentation i'm going to
go through it rather quickly um if you
have any questions
please do unmute yourself and say miguel
i have a question and pop in and ask
is the easiest way in this format um
and uh and then we will also have a
chance to have a little bit more of a
conversation so i'm gonna share
okay here we are um let me move this
here
okay today i thought that we uh
not talk about mission and vision
because i'm sure a lot you you've been
talking about this in uh in the past and
you're very familiar with that
but i thought i speak about um
the uh long-term and short
short terms uh planning for the
nonprofit going beyond
um the mission and vision
the overview of the talk is uh number
one i'm going to talk about building
your team what
what does that mean how uh what are my
what has been my experience
on criteria for building the right team
for my institution for my organization
for my mission
uh number two i'm going to talk about
building
uh your network of stakeholders those
are
the people that represent your market
who are you
bringing your services or your product
or your programs to
and number three i'm going to talk about
the sorted topic of coin
what i uh what we call the fundraising
uh part of the nonprofit sector uh and
basically
how do we capitalize how do we infuse uh
and inject um
capital into our organization and
there are two strategies that i'm going
to talk about first of all
fundraising and then i'm going to talk
about um i'm so sorry
i'm going to turn this off so that we
are not
interrupted um
and then i'm going to talk about the two
strategies fundraising which is short
term and then capitalization which is
longer term
again this is a conversation please ask
questions uh there are many ways to skin
a cat and i'm just gonna
sort of touch the surface of some of
them first of all
talking about building your team um
this is really important probably the
most important part
of the startup process first of all
choosing the people with the right
expertise what are the are areas that
you need help with what are the things
that you need to accomplish
and how do you get the right people on
board um
over the years i have been a a firm
believer of good to great it was a book
written by jim
uh collins and it sort of helps you to
think
about your institution your business
your mission
uh whatever you're trying to build as a
bus and you need to get
on the bus the right uh number of people
uh
one of the things that he he talks about
is to retain the right
the right people before embarking on any
specific pro
program is key you can get started if
you don't have a buzz running
um i always say don't look for
compliments
uh look for people that compliment you
not that are equals and what do i mean
by that
um it's very easy and i think it's the
most common mistake
um for people to hire people that have
the same affinity of you that are like
you
um it's easy to get along with people
that you feel
um have the same um
type of uh sort of mentality and
oh so sorry about this let me just
quit this there we go um
so getting people who are not just like
you but who compliment you
what are the things what are the skill
sets that you don't
have that you need to bring on board i
want
to bring people always into my
organization who complement
what i don't have um you know if my
strengths
are programmatic and my strengths are
not analytical and they are not
uh marketing then i want people who are
very strong in those areas
um not necessarily people who
uh are similar to me um
the other thing um you know the
management
of your your team management should
include people who care very deeply
about
what your mission is about your company
and who will argue passionately
for the decisions that they believe are
right even if they disagree with you
another part uh that is very important
for me
is uh to make an assessment and know the
leadership styles within my management
team
what do i mean by that over the years
there have been many ways to assess
styles leadership styles and you want to
make sure
that you have an array a variety of
styles within your
management team um they the the most for
comments and these have different names
by different theorists
um are directors analyzers expressers
and harmonizers and i'm gonna talk about
those uh in a mo in a moment
and then the last thing that i um
encourage everyone to think about when
you are
thinking about starting an institution
uh
an organization of any kind is to
um think about how does equity diversity
and inclusion
uh becomes part of your frameworks from
the beginning
how do you create an environment of
equity within your team and within your
company and that includes your
stakeholders and
um your market and
second how do you diversify in all ways
of what it means
diversity not just racial but age groups
uh skill sets all of that how do you
create
a diverse environment and how do you
become
a culture of inclusion within your team
and you build that
and that is something that has become
very uh
important today uh and funders
um in uh corporations and foundations
they are all very interested in learning
about the culture
of equity diversity and inclusion within
your organization
so let me tell you about what uh
leadership styles and what i mean by
that
um there are four leadership styles and
when we talk about these we don't
compartmentalize people within
one of those there are people that could
be um
that move between two categories but let
me just tell you a little bit about them
and why they are important and why it's
important for you
to know um the leadership styles of your
of your team
first of all we have directors these are
people who are goal-oriented
they are quick at making decisions
they're always on the go
they tell it as it is if you give them
two choices they'll make a decision
really fast
that these people get a lot done very
quickly
sometimes they can be perceived
perceived as ins
as insensitive because they don't dwell
on the on the
issues they create they look at the
solution they
make their decision and they go these
are
um very key individuals
needed in any organizations and ceos
a lot of ceos and a lot of
executive directors fall under this
category
number two are the analyzers and i
always think of analyzers as the
180 degree opposite from the directors
these are people who are very data
driven um
they are task oriented they they deal
with
process they know how to process um how
to create process
to get a product out they make lists
um they are called also thinkers
these are people that will review
data over and over and over
and they will have a conversation with
you for 20 minutes
about one particular thing analyzers can
drive
directors crazy because directors are
like
make a decision and the analyzer wants
to just
go over the data over and over again
they are sometimes perceived as
procrastinators because they take a long
time to make a decision
um however directors need analyzers
they give directors the right choices
the right um uh choices uh
to make a decision they are the people
who
think the hardest about how to solve the
problem
and what are the repercussions going to
be the directors
will look at that quickly and make a
decision
based on what the analyzers give them
but these folks
take a little bit longer and you need to
be able to identify them and work with
them
then we have the expressors these are
um especially in social services these
are people-oriented individuals they are
animated they are entertaining they are
the life of a crowd they are uh
extroverts most of the time
um they may be imprecise because
precision
and data is not their focus they are
more focused
on um learning about the person
and learning about a particular
individual
and being um attuned with them
and they are a lot of the times um
confused with the harmonizers which are
the relationship builders
these are the folks that really really
want to get
people engaged and they are they are
talkers they
um talk very calmly and precise and they
try to bring
people into the fold um they are very
loyal they are very dedicated
they are conflict avert they don't want
to argue they want to figure out how can
we solve the problem in an
amicable way um they may not over commit
they will not commit um at first glance
they will want to see how things are
going to go
um these four styles
live in every organization and hopefully
they do
if you have an organization where all
your teams are directors
there's going to be a lot of mistakes
made because
there are there's lack of data analysis
um they are going to not relate
well to their market to their
stakeholders to their board members
they are not interested in relationship
building they are
short um lived uh and one term
relationship
they are um too quick uh
and and so it is it is really important
when you're building your team that you
bring on board people that
fill these categories that fall into
these categories so that you have
a very diverse number of thinkers and
workers in your team that can um analyze
that can ex uh build relationships with
folks
can make decisions quickly um and that
is gonna get
give you an edge these are the people
that you want and on your bus
um let's see
building your network of stakeholders
the this is very important um
this is how you build the folks that are
going to be
uh supporting your organization they are
going to be
um folks that are going to bring capital
and streamline sustainability for short
and long term always remember that
everybody that you speak to
is a possible stakeholder these are
people that share
your purpose and passion
you should always have a strategy for
first-time meetings
with prospects if you are going to meet
with someone for the first time or
you're going to have a cold call
have a strategy of how you're going to
get this person
interested in your mission um you've all
heard about the 60 second or the
30-second
you know elevator speech or you know
there are many things
practice those things um you know you
need to identify
what are the things that connect you uh
with those
individuals you know um what
what do you share i i i'm always
interested
on learning what ticks that person if
you know for example if i was working at
boston baroque
um and i was meeting a donor a possible
donor for the first time i'm interested
in
what his history is with baroque music
because most probably this person is a
business person that enjoys the
the music genre so how how did they came
about
you know to the organization or to this
music genre and what is it that ticks
them i'm always curious about that
um you know have a strategy for how
you're going to do this
you should identify people within your
network
that can be board members staffs and
stakeholders and and learn how to use
your board
your staff and stakeholders as
connectors
to other prospects and individuals this
is a machine that is
ongoing it's a cycle that lives in every
organization and every ceo
and executive director lives in this
24 hour you know 365
uh cycle of generating stakeholders
um always try to connect with each
person in some way especially if they're
important stakeholders important donors
uh invest possible embed investors
um i i used to have a little trick
that i used to play when i had meetings
with
don't with prospective donors and i
didn't know them it was my first time so
i had a little uh
sort of a folder that i carry with me
and a pad where i would take notes and
inside of it on the
one side i had three pictures um this is
when i was working at opera boston i had
a picture of my
dog um i had a picture
of my niece my young niece was three
years old
and i had a picture of beverly seals a
postcard of beverly sills
and i would open it and they would look
at it and they would go oh is that your
dog
and then i thought oh right there a dog
person
so we would talk about dogs and get to
know the person
you know and get to build a relationship
a personal relationship they would look
at the picture
of my knees and you know is that your
daughter said no that's my niece and i'm
like okay children so children's
possibly an important aspect of this
individual
um beverly sills an opera lover okay
we're gonna we we're gonna talk opera
today so
find ways there this is a practice um
and it is an interpersonal practice that
you should always try
um and finally you know i can't
talk enough about the power of
grassroots
organizing even for non-profits
um social media uh and building
a core of volunteers are key for
anything that you do
and the more you grow the more you want
these things
um first of all because social media is
a powerful communication
tool it allows you to bring your message
out and information out very quickly to
many many uh individuals at once and
people in
who are your stakeholders at a very uh
no cost uh sort of uh uh
uh you know uh resource so
um i saw the other day i i got a uh
an email blast it was a social media
blast
from a hospital that we support a local
hospital
with it was a picture of a crane
putting a cat scan
machine a big casket machine into
the building um into the second floor
building and it was just a powerful
message and the
the the caption said thank you your
support made it possible that we
uh were able to purchase this new
equipment for the hospital
um and it was all done through social
media it had
hundreds and hundreds of people saw it
uh that were their stakeholders and they
felt their money
had done something wonderful so um
grassroots organizing is very very very
important and
and it's key now i'm going to spend some
time talking about
the sordid topic of coin as i like to
call it um
most of you are familiar with
fundraising
you've heard the the word you know it's
it's the the thing everybody runs away
from
uh in the non-profit when they don't
know how to do it or don't feel
comfortable with it
um it is a there are traditional methods
we're going to talk about it and then
i'm also
also going to talk about capitalization
and capitalization and fundraising are
are two different things in my book
fundraising
uh they are both two techniques uh two
strategies
for short-term and long-term
sustainability of any non-profit
um it is very important i believe today
that you have a two-prong
approach to sustainability one that uh
deals with the short term
and one that deals with the long term
how am i going to pay for
or have cash to pay for my expenses over
the next few months
and how am i going to build the capital
over the next few years to help me
sustain the organization over the first
over the next few years so those those
two things are important they are both
important and they are part of your
institutional relationship building
process
this is always ongoing and one does not
capitalize on the other
the capitalization strategy does not
take money from your regular
fundraising practices so we're going to
talk
a little bit about what that is first of
all traditional fundraising most of all
of us are familiar with it um they are
fiscal year to fiscal yields
to fiscal year strategies meaning if
your fiscal year
is uh january 1st through december 31st
your traditional fundraising strategy is
going to fund
that uh fiscal year in most non-profits
especially in the arts
there are certain categories within the
traditional
fundraising tools number one is
individual giving campaigns that's
the email blast that you get from
bso or tanglewood or the speakeasy that
asks you for money
uh sometimes is phone solicitation
sometimes it's a piece of mail it could
be a card
or a um an actual letter
more and more direct mail is
disappearing as electronic solicitations
become more
efficient and more uh prevalent in in
the system
um we have a category called major gifts
and major gifts is diff is a part
of individual giving but major gift
means
that somebody is giving you a gift of a
particular amount
that is significant to your organization
that amount can vary for some people
a hundred dollar donation is significant
if most of your donations are five ten
dollars
a hundred dollars is a big gift if you
are an organization that um
raises a lot of hundred fifty hundred
two hundred and fifty dollars
um gifts then a gift of five
hundred dollars or a thousand dollars
becomes a major gift
and that's coming from an individual
the interesting piece about major gifts
and the important part about major gifts
is that they bring more money
with less amount of work it is
it is very important to have a
grassroots
um approach to individual fundraising
where you have lots and lots and lots of
donors
but if you have if you want to raise a
hundred dollars
and you have a hundred one dollar
donors it is more difficult to go and
solicit a hundred people than
solicit two people for fifty dollars so
major gifts
are very important they also
signal to the organization that this
person has a particular
strong affinity to your mission
so they are going to be closer and a 500
gift can be turned into a thousand
dollars five thousand
and so on so major gifts are
important they are personal um and
sometimes it can take years to develop
somebody who gives ten dollars today
may turn into a fifty or a hundred
dollars or a thousand dollars later on
it may require some stewardship
and some uh conversations and some
attention but you can build it
um another source of fundraising
income is foundations and corporations
these uh gifts vary from region to
region foundations tend to
be mission driven corporations sometimes
require
marketing opportunities for them um
they are not in most places they are not
the most
uh the greater yield most organizations
especially in the arts
in greater boston and new england
are mostly supported by individual
giving and major gifts
and then um we have finally special
events and affinity groups for example
a gala event these are social
uh networking opportunities people love
a good party
uh and if you can create a special event
that uh provides people with
opportunities for social networking
they can uh they'll be coming to your
event
they are usually transactional um
one time they may come to your gala but
they may not give
to anything else um that you have in
your organization any other
opportunities
but that is okay um it's okay to have
one-time gifts
um you could have affinity groups and
what i mean by that are sometimes what
they call membership groups
if a uh an opera company or the bso has
a young
professionals affinity group uh and that
those are
young individuals under the age of 30
that can give 250
a year so they create an affinity group
and it's sort of a membership it makes
you feel like you're
part of something and you're supporting
an organization you like
or an institution and you're enjoying
and having
a group of individuals with you that
share
that affinity um some of these
relationships can be transactional as i
said it could be one time some of them
can be for
short-term relationships people and
foundations change
their focus of giving uh often uh this
year they decided that they are going to
give to organizations like yours and
next year they are going to give to
social services so um these things are
less
certain that's why traditional
fundraising is important
and it's at the core of um
any institution but they can be less
certain
and they require resources you you need
to have people dedicated solely
to doing this activity of raising money
um the ceo uh and the executive director
and the founder of any organization
is has to be intrinsically involved in
this fundraising
uh effort it is it could be 50
of his time 60 75 of his time
25 of his time it depends on how good
the fundraising machine is in place so
getting people
who know how to do this it's very
important
now i'm going to talk about capital
capitalization campaigns
um these are more certain and the reason
is that this inf
inflection or inflection of uh of cash
is in addition to what you do normally
on a traditional uh
fiscal year fundraising campaign so you
this does not substitute the other this
is
on top of these are
um campaigns that can be
uh two to three year they're multi-year
um they are not the same as a capital
campaign when you hear the word capital
campaign
is either the company is building uh
brick and mortars so either a building
or they are uh building an endowment
uh and it's uh it's a capital campaign
for that purpose capitalization
campaigns are to enhance your
institution
in the long term is to provide security
and long-term institutional uh
sustainability it they promote
stabilization
because they are multi-years so you have
an influx of cash
coming over a period of two three four
or five years
depending on their campaign they are
often
um contracted commitments if you do a
campaign
um and you have people who are gonna
give you a particular
number uh a particular amount of money
over
five years then you you draw a contract
that says i have pledged uh to this
organization or to this
company my support over the next five
years i'm gonna give
five thousand dollars every year for the
next five years so you have
25 000 already committed that is gonna
come on a yearly basis
so it when you look at the future
you know that you have some commitments
and some pledges
on top of your regular fiscal year
traditional fundraising campaign
you have an influx of cash that is going
to
make you more stable as the years come
by
we're going to talk about how you you do
that how you make the case for that
it offers the organization the
opportunity to
innovate to create
programs that you cannot do with your
traditional fundraising
to produce special projects that are one
one of a kind um that are not going to
be produced every year but maybe you
want in two years to do a particular
project
and you need to build the capital now
for that year um
it engages stakeholders and donors into
really long-term relationships and this
is key
you start to learn who in your
network in your stakeholders network
is with you for the long haul it's
really really good um
the other thing is that
donors love to give money
to organizations they feel are going to
make it
if you are building
um your future over a three or five year
plan
and you're asking for capitalization
they feel like oh
this person has long term plans
and a plan on how to do that over the
next five years i want to be part of
that
so capitalization campaigns are for me
are very exciting
um if you have a good case statement
they give you a lot of security
and then it allows you to plan more than
one year at a time
it allows you to build um an overarching
three to five year plan
with some um real capital behind it
i'm gonna give you an example of a
capitalization strategy that i built
that i helped build for boston baroque a
few years ago this was
about four years ago boston baroque is a
almost 50 years old organization in
boston
they had been always
working on a year-to-year basis and
there were some plans that the artistic
director
and the executive director wanted to put
forward for the future
that require additional funding that
they
didn't have from the the traditional
annual
fundraising strat you know fundraising
campaign
um they called it we call this the four
pillars campaign and i'm gonna
show you what what that means in a
second um we
put together a case statement and a case
statement is key for any campaign
any capitalization campaign it has to
eloquently
and succinctly and specifically define
your goals of what you want to do in the
campaign
how you want to use the money and how
are you going to build
the capital over the next five years or
whatever the length of the campaign
is um
this for this particular campaign at
boston baroque this was um
a very rough and initial
look at what we were trying to do and we
call it the
the four pillars campaign because they
sustain
the missions and programs as you can see
there boston baroque as an institution
is defined and put together by its
missions and programs
and then the pillars are the things that
make
the mission and programs possible
there were four things that we
identified through a strategic planning
process that were key to the
stakeholders and the board
of this organization number one they had
to do with artistic excellence
we wanted to become financially stable
over a long period of time
not just on an annual basis we wanted to
enhance
our community and outreach and education
programs
and we wanted to enhance our
institutional disability
and i will tell you what the specifics
under each
one of those categories on each column
there's a number of activities that
define
those elements um
we decided that this campaign was going
to be a two million dollar campaign to
be raised over
two over five years two million dollars
over a five year period
and what is this money going to
fund well on the first pillar as you see
artistic
investment the artistic um
excellence part column of this uh
campaign we wanted to in
in uh input a an extra 175
000 into our opera productions
to make them more um technologically
technology um interesting
enhancing the quality uh of the
presentations
uh at a theater that was not a
proscenium
we wanted to increase the level of our
guest
soloists we wanted to bring people who
are
working at the top of their artistic
excellence
that are performing at the top of
america's theaters today um
we wanted to bring uh boston baroque
which is a period instrument
orchestra we wanted to bring uh players
of particular instruments that normally
we would not find
people here in boston so over five years
in we were looking to make a six hundred
thousand dollar
investment over a five-year period into
our artistic product then financial
stability
we wanted to put over five years a 500
000 investment to stabilize the
organization and how are we going to do
that
first of all um build capacity
over a two-year p period and when we
talk about building capacity means
bringing on board uh staff
and team members that can help us raise
money for going forward so we would
invest over two year period over a two
year period
um 150 000 to bring
a couple of new staff members and then
those people will stay
and become part of the development uh
machine within the organization
organization
and then we also wanted to have some
cash reserves for the organization
in case things like a pandemic happen
right
um you don't wanna you wanna have some
cash so that you don't go under
so we figure that over a five year
period
we would raise three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars of a cash reserve
fund uh the third one was community
outreach and education we wanted to
invest
a hundred thousand dollars into free
community concerts
we were doing that uh already but we
wanted to build a residency program
we wanted to invest a hundred thousand
dollars into our classics for
kids commissions and concerts um
for a total of two hundred thousand
dollars over five years
then the institutional visibility part
was very interesting um it was a
category that encompassed
things that we didn't know what to put
him under and we came up with
institutional visibility because
eventually eventually that's what this
was going to do number one
we wanted to uh build three recording
projects
over the next five years um
cd recording studio recorded productions
um of operas uh
under our label we wanted to
invest in something that we call boston
baroque radio which is a 24
7 digital radio station that we have um
we wanted to establish a presence in new
york city
uh doing tours uh and and having a
concert
series in new york city yearly and we
wanted to have
more run outs more touring opportunities
uh going to tanglewood ravinia and some
of the summer festivals
in all the institutional visibility was
a seven hundred thousand dollar
investment
uh over five years for the total that
campaign two million
so the question is okay so you have a
plan
you know what you want to do and how you
want to spend the money so how do you
raise the money
on a capital a capitalization campaign
so we came up with a um an interesting
chart we figured okay this is a five
year campaign
we are going to raise this capital
over five years um there the
in yellow are the fiscal years and the
first column is how many donors at the
different categories do we
have and we sort of looked at
our um donor pool to see
we could identify some prospects and
have our stakeholders help us identify
prospects and then made a commitment
these are the number of people
that we think we can get on the first
year on the second year
on the third year and what you see
happens
is that over a period of five years you
bring
all that two million dollars in on the
first year of the campaign
we were able to bring 288 000
on the second year another 385
and so on and so on so what you're doing
is you're infusing capital
to your organization over a five-year
period
above and separate from your regular
fundraising
this is not easy this is it involves
everybody's commitment
most campaigns capitalization campaigns
or capital campaigns
are done um they undergo a quiet
phase for the first few years until you
have 50
of the capital raise of the commitments
race
um once you have 50 of your pledges you
go public
um and then people get very excited and
they want to get you to the finish line
but it involves extra work and
commitment but what you end up learning
is who are the folks who have interest
in your organization
who want to become big stakeholders with
with you
and want to give you a sustainable plan
over five years
um you know what are the what are
people's interests
you know and these plans can change if
you know
in the middle of this you encounter a
pandemic you have to look at your plan
and make changes these are living uh
plans
you know so you you're always adapting
and changing but you have a purpose
and that is to capitalize your
organization for whatever the reasons
that you want to do that for um and i
think that's
i'm gonna stop there and i i'm gonna
answer questions and i know i've thrown
a lot of information some of it may make
sense some of it doesn't so
i'm gonna open it up and shannon rose
you can help with that
absolutely so i'm switching us back to
gallery view so that we can have a more
sort of peer-to-peer kind of
conversation
this was fantastic um so i think before
we get into any of the questions that i
might have had why don't we open it up
um
it looks like evan has a question
fantastic thank you so much
um so i have i do have a question on the
on the last slide you had but before
getting to that
um i'm curious as to uh just
taxes uh and different things that
501c3s
qualify for and interesting things that
we can do
for our you know multi-million dollar
folks who are looking to
you know get tax write-offs for you know
500
000 or whatever it may be so your
question is about taxes so
uh non-profits are tax tax exempt
uh anybody that gives you a gift is
tax deductible to the extent of the law
i know that the laws have gotten a
little bit tougher
um uh in the in the last administration
in terms of
the amount of money that you have to
give before it becomes a write-off
because the individual
deduction is higher than most
people's contributions to non-profits
but they are all
everything that you get um into your
capital
is tax deductible um
the only things that you may pay some
taxes on
our products such as if you sell cds
um there's some sort of taxation to that
it's minimum
um but other than that any any gift
is going to be tax deductible is that
the question
yeah i i guess it's going more into the
nuances so
i understand 501 c 3s are tax deductible
but i'm curious as to
the the specific brackets
that might be compelling to people of
like you know
should it makes no difference for me to
uh to request 750 000 versus a million
dollars but maybe there's some break
at 882 000 that it actually
incentivizes that person to give a
larger donation when it's on the bubble
there
um so let me just tell you how donors
think donors don't look at
the bracket that they want to give they
look at
how much do i i have to offer um most
people
most donors and people of wealth who
have a philanthropic
a tradition they they
they get from their investment portfolio
folks managers
and they say i want to be able to i want
i'm philanthropic i want to continue
that you tell me how much i can give
every year
the the the key thing if you have a good
development machine
in place and people who are
knowledgeable about
major gifts they will do research and
prospect
each potential donor so what the way it
works is that
if you have a person if it is an
individual
that you're going to do a major ask
let's say do i ask for 75 000 or do i go
for 150
you need to prospect them and there are
tools available to development folks
where they can look at the history
giving history of each individual
because every
gift that is given in the nonprofit is
registered somewhere out there
so they can pull that data and say this
this
donor's biggest gift is 50 000
so you don't want to overshoot because
it will turn them off
because then they'll think that they're
50 if you ask for 150
and they normally don't give more than
50 000
they may go oh they are they're looking
for a bigger donor than i am i'm gonna
pass
so you don't want to do that so it's not
how they fall in what bracket
it's more what is their giving history
and tradition and you need to do your
homework as part of your
development work on learning about that
donor
what does he give to how much um
and and then the tools will tell you the
most likely gift that you can ask and
then you ask for a little bit more
if they normally give 50 i would ask for
75
and hopefully they'll land somewhere in
between
does that happen and then in terms of
approaching a
foundation versus a high net worth
individual what are some considerations
that you have from a tax standpoint
the same way there are no tax
implications uh
for a foundation they are also um
non-profits themselves when they are
established
it is all about their history giving how
much do they have
they you know the foundations normally
work we have a pool of money we have a
million dollars to get this year
and how we're going to divvy the pie um
most
um foundations have an annual report
that will tell you in a pie chart how
much
they give to um
to universities and education how much
they give to hospitals social services
and art and cultural organizations and
then you know
what your slice of the pie is um
so that's that's sort of how you deal
with it
it's exactly the same and and most
most times most foundations guidelines
will tell you their maximum gift
great thanks so then you ask for the
maximum right
absolutely every time do you have any um
we have a few questions that uh shannon
rose and i have talked about do you have
any other questions from people who
are uh you know attending and not a
workshop post
okay i have a question can you hear me
yeah go ahead yep uh my name is joseph
webb by way of background
my startup won uh one of the mit
hackathons in june
uh in the knowledge economy track and uh
we're building a marketplace uh to
provide
ai products and services um sort of
productizing it and removing the
friction for companies
and over the last few years i did some
work for the
h the harvard business school alumni the
community partners program where we
volunteer and do
consulting for non-profits in new york
city and um
and the bay area and one thing i found
that's really common
is the difficulty in these non-profits
with
visualizing the impact of their work so
that they can raise
more money uh number two they don't have
a data strategy and number three they're
really bad with everything digital
marketing and social media
uh so my question to you miguel is um
we're working on a product
where we can um allow non-profits
to have access to a data science team
sort of uh let's say on a monthly like a
subscription basis so let's say for 500
you have one data scientist that would
work on visualizing all your work
so i just wanted to get your feedback on
that idea i i think it's
if i can connect with you afterwards um
i think the reason
um that you see that is non-profits
are based you know they work out of
mission ambition they they have a
mission and
they are one of the the most common um
issues that we see is um
that that they they they are program
people they if they if the mission is
um an orchestra they are musicians
they're they don't know the business
side of it they don't know the tools
they don't
they are not data analytical people
um if it is a social services if it is
feeding the
the the uh the hunger then they are
you know their program they're dedicated
they don't know this
the importance of data analysis and all
of that so yeah so
that's why you you saw that and you were
experiencing it and these are really
great dedicated people with great
missions
but they get stuck in a cycle that
doesn't allow them to grow
unless they bring on board people with
the technology with that with the
knowledge and
the skill to do what you're offering i
think it's
great idea if you can do that
um it'll be very interesting to see how
how difficult it is for you to analyze
qualitative data versus
you know quantitative data it's easier
to not to say
how many people we feed um
it's much harder to say how many people
we
we bring out of poverty because that's a
different analysis you know
but i think it's phenomenal i mean what
a great idea and yes
most small mid-level non-profits
don't have the skill sets for that thank
you i like the persona that you
mentioned of the analyzer so
hopefully if you can please share your
email i'd love to connect with you and
share that with you thank you so much so
piggybacking off of one of those i've
got one
um having a long and storied history and
under-resourced non-profits myself um
there's sort of a baggage element that
surrounds this sort of lean
non-profit mentality and it kind of
negatively impacts arts driven
startup organizations so how do you
recommend sort of
planning thinking budgeting for
sustainability
to avoid the kind of burnout and other
difficulties that are all too prevalent
and the sort of shortcomings that were
just brought up
you need you need to think big um if you
are going to venture in a non-profit
think big what is the overarching goal
how do you get there
and then bring people on board that can
help you with it
um most people who are founding members
or founding directors of an organization
they are again
program folks they know how to do what
what they
the product that they want to create
they just don't know how to capitalize
it
um so it is hard you need to
you need to be entrepreneurial it
doesn't matter if you're in the arts or
social services or hospital
you need to be entrepreneurial and come
up with a business plan
that gives you the capital that you need
um
don't under fund don't be lean you make
your case to every donor
that you meet um you know i cannot do it
with fifty dollars i need a hundred
you know fifty dollars will
will not allow me to survive going
forward and this is very important
you need to be very compelling in your
message
to every single person um it then
the other piece is board members you
need to build a board of people
that not only believe in your mission
but who can help you
fund it who are connected um
and you need to be very savvy it's going
to be a mixture of people who
have capacity to give you a big check
and people who who don't have capacity
but who can
make connections for you um learn the
skills that you don't know if you are
starting a non-profit and you don't know
how to ask for money
learn it it's it's not um
a rocket science it's it's an art
um you know ask for advice get money
ask for money get advice so
when you don't know a person or you know
ask for advice call them up can i have
coffee with you i have a project
and i and i would love your advice and
see if they get
interested in your project and then get
them on board
stewardship takes time it takes time but
you
it has to happen constantly and don't do
things on your own don't ever be alone
um
get a lot of people around you that
share your passion
and and then you can do it but don't
under
budget um don't settle
just be tenacious um there's a good book
called
the ultimate sales machine and it talks
about pig-headed
persistency um i i think it's key in
nonprofit work
that's really great advice and i think
that is definitely applicable to
uh all different types of ventures and
all the different kind of students
who will be competing in this
competition and speaking of if you have
kind of
one takeaway or one one pearl of wisdom
that you would give
to students who are looking to enter a
arch-related venture in this competition
what would that be
you know i would say work from purpose
um you know what is your purpose
i discovered admit career um when i was
debating uh whether to go into political
advocacy or
fundraising you know in a more
bigger way um i went through a whole
executive
uh training program in over the year
period of this program i learned what my
purpose was
which was the arts and it was music and
it was working with artists
um and i when i decided yeah that's my
purpose then work from it
everything fell into place you know i
was very excited that
the interesting interesting part is when
i talk to folks about what i do or
or a product that i'm selling what they
say so wow you're so excited about it
and i never think about it but i guess i
am because i am
i'm working on purpose so find your
purpose
work on purpose um that's the number
the one thing everything else will fall
in place
i couldn't have asked for a better
conclusion we're coming sort of to the
end
if anybody else has any final wrap-up
questions from miguel you know speak now
make yourself known
going going
gone we will have miguel share his email
in the chat
i've popped his linkedin into the chat
as well we'll be making the recording of
this video available for
asynchronous engagement we'll have a
copy of the slides that'll be available
um we're going to be sort of judging
everything and putting recordings up
first week of january
if you're burning for something sooner
than that please send me an email
i'll pop my email in the chat and
since there doesn't seem to be anything
else i'm going to close this out with a
big thanks to miguel
thank you so many salient points this
the drive of this competition is really
about strategizing
storytelling team building and
articulating
so many of the things that you hit on
tonight so i couldn't have asked for
anything better
and it was wonderful to have you here
good luck to you all and happy holidays